اتفقت الدول المشاركه في مؤتمر الامم
المتحده للمناخ كوبا 27
بالاجماع على اتفاق شامل لمواجهه التغيرات
المناخيه وخفض الانبعاثات الكربونيه بشكل
سريع لذلك في جلسه عامه ختاميه في شرم
الشيخ بمصر الجدير بالذكر ان المشاركين في
المؤتمر اتفقوا على انشاء الصندوق للخسائر
والاضرار لمساعده الدول الناميه على تحمل
التكاليف الفوريه لتداعيات الناجمه عن
تغير المناخ مثل العواصف والفيضانات
وقال نائب رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه
او تجنب او او تجنب او تقلل الخسائر
والاطراف
عند خروجكم من هذه القاعه باننا جميعا
فشلنا في اجراءات تجنب او تقليل الخسائر
والاضرار وكان ينبغي علينا فعل المزيد
يتوقع مواطنون منا ان نقلل الانبعاثات
بشكل اسرع بكثير وهذه هي طريقه الحد من
تغير المناخ وليست الانتظار والاستجابه
بمجرد ان يكون لتغير المناخ تاثيره المدمر